Yeah, but have you seen any receipts?
>> Where else could this money be going?
And they they're openly explicitly
anti-doxing. Whenever anybody who doxes
or anybody who's complicit in any of
that [__] uh gets outed as doing that,
they're banned from the Discord. They're
even banned from YouTube chat. Even if
they're not like active in the YouTube
chat
>> after Sure. So, after the Max Striker um
when
I'm not saying that
>> you made a claim just you can say that
not Hold on. Take that one back. Hold
on. Take that one back. Hold on.
>> Hold on. I want I want you to really
quick I'll let you I'll let you finish
your rant without any interruptions. I
swear but on this point specifically I
want like a genuine concession like hey
I was wrong about that. If I am right I
just don't have a clip on me. I can't
prove it. So as of now it's like I I
said something that was just wrong. Can
you do that?
>> Sure. Yeah. So well I mean concession
about what specifically? Like
>> unless you want to sit here for like 5
minutes and wait for someone to send me
a clip.
>> Okay. And she just left. Yeah. Based
[Music]
Thank you for the Yo, what's up,
>> dude? This cat meow person, don't debate
him. He's a troll. Your your chat is
full of anti-content little freaks. You
know that?
>> Uh, no.
>> You don't know that or you disagree?
What does the no there mean?
>> Oh, no. I No, I totally didn't know
that. What? That's crazy.
>> I don't understand. I don't understand
what you're trying What do What do I
want to talk about?
>> I watched your Destiny conversation
yesterday. A bit of it towards the end,
I think, or maybe in the middle. I
didn't watch at the start.
>> And it seems it it seemed like uh when
he would say something or when he would
give a take, you would just you wouldn't
give any push back. And I wanted to I
wanted to press you on that a bit.
>> Which part specifically?
>> The the recent the recent Willie Mac
stuff. It seems like you're you're on
the train that that Quean and Jtock and
all these people are like evil Kiwi
Farms doxers.
>> No. What the heck? That's like the
opposite of my takes. What?
>> Why didn't you push back on whatever
Destiny was saying then?
>> Wait, what do you mean? What did he say
specifically? You need to give me
examples. You can't just say, "Oh, yeah.
Why didn't you push back with no
examples?" No.
>> Okay. Well, I don't have I don't have
examples, but I don't I believe you
didn't push back at all.
>> Okay. All right. You can't just say,
"Oh, yeah. I feel I feel this happened.
I feel this examp,
man.
>> Okay. All right, dude. All right. Let me
know when you got examples." Okay.
>> Jesus.
>> So, you're just refusing to talk unless
I get you like a clip.
>> Uh, I mean, do do you have any examples?
Cuz I certainly didn't think that this
was an issue. So, it's like I I don't
even know. It's like it's like why do I
have to dig up clips where I don't
believe there was an issue for you,
right? Like why
>> I don't think you need to I'm talking to
you right now. We don't need to even do
clips.
>> Um,
okay. I mean, that's
>> the top of my head, Destiny D at one
point Destiny was like,
>> "Oh, well, like he he just basically
read off all of the docks and criticism,
right? but just like in the fast
sarcastic voice and then you just like
laughed as like obviously implicitly
supporting that, right? But it it seems
like all that criticism against Destiny
is valid. Like why is Destiny suddenly
anti- Kiwi Farms when he was, you know,
okay with it existing in the past,
right?
>> I don't think Destiny was ever anti Kiwi
Farms generally, right? Does that make
sense?
>> He is now,
>> bro. He is the same person who defended
Kiwi Farms hardcore. He was fighting on
the front lines against Kiwi farms.
>> You think he's pro kiwi farms now? No.
>> No. He's always been ambivalent about
it. No.
>> You don't think he's anti- Kiwi Farms
now?
>> He is anti- Kiwi Farms only in the sense
that he has an active threat on him and
he hates it.
>> Why does he hate the threat?
>> Like but but but like the existence of
Kiwi Farms. We're talking about the
existence of Kiwi Farms. I I don't think
he's ever argued against the existence
of the site itself. No, he doesn't even
he doesn't even think there's something
inherently wrong about his own [__]
thread on Kiwi Farms because Kiwi
Farmers can kiwi farm,
>> so who cares?
>> True. True. I love Kiwi Farms. Why does
he associate Kiwi Farms with people who
are like against him?
>> He hasn't he hasn't said that either. He
>> hasn't associated Kiwi farms with people
who go against him like Queen or Jtock
or like Pisco.
Wait, what the [__] Cuz Kiwi Farms is
unhinged. Wait, but how do you how do
you mean by that?
>> Kiwi. Okay, Kiwi Farms is how is Kiwi
Farms unhinged?
>> I mean, I took a look today and you know
they were they if you do search up my
name. Listen, I'm just saying. Okay.
They they call me a Vietnamese cashier.
All right. What the [__] Yeah, that's
unhinged. What? How am I cashier? I've
never even worked in a grocery store.
Yeah,
>> they're unhinged because you've never
worked in a grocery store.
>> Yeah. And also they they they ask for my
dogs. It's [__] weird. Like what the
[__] That's weird.
>> How is that different from any other
like forum or or social media? People do
that on Twitter.
>> Um
but Kiwi Farms is like this coalesed
community. Like if you if you look at
Twitter, it's like a lot bigger. It's a
lot broader, right? But if you look at
Kiwi Farms, it's like this more niche
coalesed like niche space. No, like no
one would ever in good faith compare
Twitter with Kiwi Farms. That's insane,
right?
That's a crazy comparison.
>> How's that a crazy comparison?
>> Okay, I can't tell if you're being good
faith or not. Like, what do you mean?
>> You can't tell. I'm asking you a
question. Okay. Twitter. Twitter is this
widespaning website hosted by Elon Musk.
Okay. The richest man in the world where
what they do is
I'll ask a better question on the site.
Hold on. You want me to list the [__]
differences? So, I will. Okay. [__] Let
me just finish this first. Okay. So,
>> okay.
>> What is What is the difference between
Destiny posting a docs on Twitter and
then someone posting a docs on Kiwi
Farms?
Um well the difference is that Destiny
is retaliatory in that sense. No like
the thing is is that he feels like he's
justified in the sense but people will
like dox on Kiwi farms because
>> I mean I feel like if you have people
like perpetuating like the [__]
infinite rape narrative about like
someone and they want to bring down your
downfall. Do you not want to do that?
>> Yes. Basically JTO Yes. Basically, JTOK
says that there is a bunch of like
[__] um mentally ill woman that
Destiny deliberately targets or
deliberately what JTO has ever said in
order to
>> JTO has never said that.
>> Okay, you didn't even let me finish
though. Okay.
>> No, because the infinite rate machine
isn't a JTO talking point. It's a
President Sunday talking point.
>> Okay, that's great. But, you know, he
spreads it so who cares.
>> No. Okay. The the infinite rape machine
is a is a hypothetical. Let's say food
shops. Every single day a girl is raped,
but none of the women want to come out
and it's just one person uh you know
doing the raping, right? When is it
ethical for you to go against the
woman's consent to out the fact that
they're getting raped to stop the rape
even though they don't want it to come
out, right? That is the justification
that President Sunday used to go against
Pixie's wishes and out the fact that she
had revenge porn spread of her. Right.
Revenge porn colloquially, I guess. You
You've asked me. You You asked me. You
asked me a lot of questions. Okay. So,
can I ask one back? Is that okay?
>> Uh, okay. Smile.
>> Okay. So, Pixie right now has a
GoFundMe. All right. Where $53,000
have been raised for her. Okay. As far
as I'm concerned, I'm sure that you'll
agree that accountability is important.
Do you remember CEO and the 100K
GoFundMe and how we were all laring on
CEO on that?
>> Why don't we demand any receipts for
Pixie? Where are the receipts? Did I
miss
>> Do you have reasonable suspicion that
she's not using it for the legal case?
>> I don't know.
>> I believe had reasonable suspicion that
she wasn't using it for what she said
she was using it. And then furthermore,
No, stop talking. Come on. Let me
finish. Let me finish. You want Listen,
listen.
>> You don't have reasonable suspicion,
first of all. So, I think it's unfair to
demand that. And then second of all,
Destiny on your stream yesterday said
he's spending upwards of 300K on this uh
lawsuit, on this legal case, right? uh
if she's only raised 50k acting as if
she is Pexi is like this this some sort
of like Nepo baby or some sort of rich
[__] savant that has like an absurd
amount of money uh that she can use on a
legal case is is I think really naive
and shortsighted. I think if she is
using money obviously a good chunk of it
a good majority of it at least is coming
from the GoFundMe if not all of it. Uh
so first of all I think it's unfair to
even ask for receipts if there's no
reasonable suspicion. If your suspicion
is just like, okay, well, Keeles did
this, uh, I don't think that's good
because Keeles and Pixie are obviously
two very different people. Um, and they
the circumstances around why they wanted
money are very, very different. Uh, and
then also, uh, legal cases are
expensive. I don't think she has a ton
of money in her bank. And even if she is
paying for this out of pocket for
whatever reason, right? If Destiny is
paying upwards of 300,000, how much is
she paying? And if she is paying out of
pocket, then that money from the
GoFundMe is just replacing that. So more
or less it is just going to the legal
fund, right?
>> So for somebody who has raised 50,000,
you don't want to demand any kind of
receipts for that, especially not to the
people who have donated. Like it's kind
of crazy to me how like oh yeah say he
was paying illegal funds last night on
your stream.
>> Over 300k at this point. But the thing
is he has to pay so far.
>> I mean I don't [__] know, right? I
don't know anything about like the law
who's filing, who's not.
>> I don't care if you know. I don't know.
[__]
>> I don't know anything about Florida
filing. Like, isn't it isn't it the case
that if you file a lawsuit in Florida,
it's like $200 or $300, but if you pay
for lawyer services, it's like a lot
more, dude. Like, in terms of like she's
paying for lawyers, right? She's paying
for lawyers. Lawyers are expensive.
>> This money is probably going to the
legal case, right?
>> How do you know?
>> Where where else where else could this
money be going? Yeah, but have you seen
any receipts?
>> Where else could this money be going?
>> I maybe you should ask her. I mean,
people have donated to her. No.
>> Where else could this money be going? Do
you have Has she post like any any
reasonable suspicion? Has she posted
that she got like a new car or a [__]
Xbox on Twitter? Has she talked about
spending this money on anything else? Is
there any sort of reasonable suspicion?
Or has she mostly stayed quiet and
worked on the legal case in private,
most likely using the money she got from
the the GoFundMe? The legal case also
isn't even over, right? So, she doesn't
know how much she's going to spend, how
much he's going to need, all of this,
right? There there's there's so much
into this. We're like at the beginning
of the legal case, more or less. It's
going to take like another year to
finish. Probably 2 years, who knows,
right? So, demanding receipts right now,
I think, is a little unfair because
people could still donate. She could
still use the money. Not all of the
money is being used. This is just like
you out of nowhere demanding receipts uh
just like as a as a what aboutism. Like,
what about Keflles? Keles did this thing
so Pixie could also do it. It's like,
okay, I don't care about Pixie. I care
about what Destiny's doing, first of
all. Uh, if Pixie is like scamming
people out of money, yeah, that's bad.
Sure. But, you know, I don't really give
a [__] right? I I care about what
Destiny's doing.
>> Okay.
I just think it's weird there's no
receipts, but okay.
>> Yeah. I don't I don't give a [__] I
don't care. That's not any of my
priorities. What what is the So why what
is Destiny's justification for trying to
dox people like Quimman or Jtock? Why is
that justified?
>> I don't know. Cuz they've just been
spending like [__] every day or like
constant streams about like talking
about, oh yeah, this is how Destiny gets
its victims. This is how it happens.
This like how X and Y happens, right?
Like the [__] I mean, at that point,
like if you're unjustified,
Destiny,
>> hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on, hold
on, hold on. If you perpetuate a space,
if you perpetuate a space in which you
enable this kind of behavior, is it not
the case that you can make a
justification for doxing?
>> What behavior?
>> So like basically all right so if you're
like contributing towards a space right
especially when you're saying oh yeah
this person is like a rapist this person
is like a sex sex abuser this person
should belong on the list or something
like that. Like the thing is is that
when it comes to something like that
then yeah I mean in that case like
especially when Kiwi Farms is going like
oh well you know if it is the case that
um because it's it's very clear to me
that they're like playing footsy with
Kiwi Farms. You can't ever point out
like one specific example where like
because the most frustrating thing is
that you can't point out like one
example. I don't think that they're the
ones that coordinating the doxing or
something like that. But it's very clear
to me that like they are okay with it.
Right. I don't think they give a [__]
about whether or not Destiny is doxed or
not. Right. So if they don't give a
[__] they don't like say,
>> "Yeah, Queen and J."
>> Okay, first Destiny is like himself.
There's no reason for them to care.
First of all, no. First of all, there's
no reason for them to care. Destiny has
all of his [__] out there. He he has
essentially doxed himself, first of all.
And they are openly explicitly
anti-doxing. Whenever anybody who doxes
or anybody who's complicit in any of
that [__] uh gets outed as doing that,
they're banned from the Discord. They're
even banned from YouTube chat. even if
they're not like active in the YouTube
chat, it's like, yeah, these people are,
you know, explicitly removed from the
communities. They say, "Hey, doxing is
bad. I don't agree with that. Don't do
that." Right? Whereas Destiny is saying
like, "Yeah, anybody who has a dox
available, I'm going to spread it. I'm
going to leak it. Anybody like we need
to doxman. We need to dox JTO. These
people are just critical of Destiny."
Right.
You don't think that there's you don't
think that there's any kind of
justification especially any
justification for doxing? Absolutely
none. Because justification for
something like that when when doxing can
lead to real world harm like swatting uh
like you know [__] whatever threats.
Uh there was absolutely no
justification. Uh, as easily as someone
could justify as easily as Destiny could
justify doxing Quan, someone could
justify doxing you and swatting you
because you've admitted to like being a
pedophile, right?
>> Then then what is your then what is your
take on the whole like Queen Willy Max
situation where he had like [__]
Willie Max like docs up?
>> Uh, he was responding to a Destiny
tweet. He was reacting to a Destiny
tweet, right? So I I think the fault
ultimately is on Destiny, right? Um, I
think
yeah, the 1000% defaults on Destiny.
Destiny responded to the tweet
amplifying it, right? I here's how I
view DX's. Okay, first of all, I I
believe at this point, and obviously I
could be wrong. Um, I don't have the the
timeline in front of me.
>> You don't Okay, hold on. Hold on. You
don't think there's something?
>> I don't have the timeline in front of
me. I don't have the timeline in front
of me. Listen, listen, listen, listen,
listen. Food chops, listen.
>> No, no. I I acknowledges his docs. You
are allowed to scrutinize it and talk
about it, right?
>> Okay.
So, first of all, uh I believe at this
point Willie had acknowledged and
confirmed his docs and also uh Quimman
was criticizing a Destiny tweet, right?
He was saying, "Hey, this is critical."
>> No, no, no, no, no. I just think it's
really crazy like to me how you say
like, "Oh, yeah, Queen GTO is against
doxing." But then Queman literally on a
stream where he lambasted Willie Mack
all day. He shows Willie M's like
information on stream. He had it up. I
don't think Quman is stupid. All right?
Because maybe you think Quimma is stupid
and maybe you think Quum is a [__]
like [__] teenager or some [__] But
I think that Queman is relatively a
smart person. I think that when he had
Willy Doest
Destiny
>> I mean he was just saying like, "Oh
yeah, these people are like [__]
doxing um Willy Mack." No, hold on. I
can pull it up.
Why? Why does that matter? What's your
point?
>> What I mean? All right, hold on. Let me
pull it up as well then.
>> Like what's the point? Like like tell me
the point first.
>> The point
>> what is this supposed to prove? Yeah.
>> So he replies to a gate fumodor post uh
which I believe at the time the gateto
fumodor post had like multiple hundreds
of thousands of views, right? It was at
like 300,000 Twitter views. Uh and then
also this was a clip of the bad pan
video which had upwards of like 60,000
views at the time as well. Destiny
responds to this saying anything
involving this be guy or anyone that
supports him is justifiable. He is
responding to a dox. He's responding to
Willy's docs saying, "Hey, if you dox
people, anything against you is
justifiable." Okay, Willie has been
explicitly linking it to me. Can you
link it to me? Hold on. Can you link it
to me?
>> I can send you a screenshot. I think
it's taken down at this point,
>> I guess. Okay, so let me finish my point
cuz I didn't even get to my point yet.
So, the thing is is that when you have
Max Striker films, okay, so he is
somebody who is known to have like edgy
[__] super chats and like chats,
right? like he's he's like a known
community member who is known to do like
[__] edgy chats, right? So, you have
somebody who I I don't even know if he's
been punished before for like saying
like outlandish things, but like the
thing is for Hold on, hold on, hold on,
hold on. Let me lead up to it. So, when
we're in a dynamic conversation, let
hold on an entire
food shops. You said he I don't even
know if he's been punished for saying
these things. Does he need to be? Is
there an obligation to be punished?
I mean, the thing is is that it's kind
of crazy to me that you don't peopleize
this kind of behavior, right?
>> Yeah. Especially when they're giving
super chats of like, why the [__] not?
He's literally saying, "Yeah, mission
like mission accomplished." Whatever.
>> I know. I know. I know it's a joke. Yes,
it is obvious. How could you How could
you Hold on. But how could you blame
anybody? How could you blame anybody for
like think you should be punished for
doing that like another way?
>> Also, what the [__] This joke thing is
so [__] ridiculous as well, right?
Because because the thing is is that
yeah, maybe you should. The reason for
this is because like edgy jokes or like
an edgy way of saying something in a
humorous way seems to be like a catch
all for like justifying like any kind of
commentary that you give, right? Like
for example, whenever Queen puts
everything in a very smiley voice, in a
very like laughing voice or something
like that, like is it not the case that
like in a way you can all just say, "Oh
yeah, it's all just jokes." Right? This
is the modern Bailey of commentary.
Whenever somebody presses on you and
say, "Um, oh yeah, aren't you doing
this?" You can just say, "Oh, it's just
a joke." Hold on. Hold on. Let me
explain. So after, Sure. So after the m
Max striker, um, when
I'm not saying that
>> after the mic striker, his response to
Max Striker.
>> Yeah. Because he saw it as a joke. He
didn't see it as a serious call to
action. You made the claim that that
this is something Queman does like a
lot, right?
>> And it is it is it not his fault? And is
it not his fault? When has done this?
When has made a serious criticism, then
when he's called out, he's claimed, "Oh,
well, I was just trolling." When has he
done that?
>> In terms of serious criticism
>> or something, when has Queen made a
serious criticism and then when he's
called out on it or challenged on it, he
he takes it back and says, "Oh, I was
just trolling. I was just joking." Has
he ever done that?
Um, I mean I'm just talking about the
mod and bailey of commentary, but I mean
>> that's Queen.
>> That's what I'm saying.
>> You made a claim. Just you can say that
probably not. Hold on. Hold on. Take
that one back. Hold on. Take that one
back. Hold on. I mean, probably I don't
know about Queen specifically, but the
thing is is that is it is is it not the
tone of his streams? Like it's more like
when people decide
specifically himself. I think it's
fairly obvious when he has a serious
point, when he has a serious criticism,
and then when he doesn't, right, when
he's joking, I think there's a fairly
obvious uh, you know, switch in tone
there
>> and the fact that you don't have any
examples to like counter this, you're
you're just saying [__] and then when
you're countered on it, you have nothing
to say.
>> I want I want you to really quick, I'll
let you I'll let you finish your rant
without any interruptions, I swear. But
on this point specifically, I want like
a genuine concession like, "Hey, I was
wrong about that." If I am right, I just
don't have a clip on me. I can't prove
it. So, as of now, it's like I I said
something that was just wrong. Can you
do that?
>> Sure. Yeah. So, well, I mean, concession
about what specifically I guess
>> saying that Queen does like short [__]
[__]
>> I mean, I mean, it's funny. It's it's
it's funny to me how like you say, "Oh,
yeah, you have to bring up clips or
something like that." Meanwhile, you
haven't brought up an example just
didn't even give any push. I don't need
a clip. I don't need a clip. I don't
want a clip. I don't see a clip. I don't
want a clip. I'm not asking for a clip.
I never chat. You said this was only a
chat and then you told me literally
>> we are talking
verbal. Speak speaking right now. Then
I'm just talking right now too.
>> I don't want a clip.
>> All right.
>> I don't require a clip. I'm not ask you
for a clip. Like why the [__] Okay. All
right.
>> I don't want a clip. When I ask you for
one example, I want you to tell me. So
like, okay. Well, here's a time I
remember him doing this.
>> Example, for example, right? I mean,
that's the thing. No.
>> Okay. So, you can't provide an example.
Why the [__] should I No, hold on. Hold
on. Here. Here's what's going on. Here's
what's going on. I asked you for an
official concession. You said yes. And
you don't want to do that. So, now
you're going back and trying to be
critical, right? You're trying to be
critical of my position. I don't want
clips. I don't want clips. I don't want
to do the clip game where where we're
each pulling up.
>> I'll give you a concession. No.
>> No. I'm not going to give you a
concession if you like.
>> Okay. So, No, you're wrong. And now
you're refusing to concede. It's okay.
Sure.
>> Yeah. And you're accusing me of being
bad faith and you're refusing to
concede.
>> Hold on. Let me let me finish. At least
let me finish the Max Striker example
first.
>> No, concede.
>> Didn't you say you're going to let me
finish?
>> Yes. If you conceded say that you were
wrong about Queen, you said something
that was untrue. You said something that
was untrue.
>> How gay is it to just like demand
someone to concede? Like
>> you are a transgender lollycon. Don't
talk to me about being gay,
[__] Okay, we're both gay here.
We're both gay. We're not even okay. Um,
okay. All right. I mean, if you say so.
I didn't know that about you, but okay.
I guess you're coming out the closet
right now.
>> True. Can you concede
>> about what? Like, you didn't even say
anything. And why the [__] should I
consume?
>> You said you said Que will make a
serious criticism and then when he is
pushed on that, he will take it back and
use the excuse, oh, I was just trolling.
And then you said, I can't think of
anything. I don't even want a clip. I've
never asked you for specifically. It's
when people defend Queen, right? Like
the thing is this. Wait, is it not
>> defend? When has someone defended Queen?
>> Hold on. I just remembered. I just
remembered. I just remembered. I just
remembered.
>> When has anybody defended Queen with
that excuse?
>> Hold on. Is it not the case that Hold
on. I can actually bring up myself
actually. um when Quimman was covering
me way back in the day and then when I
am like pushing back against him and
actually criticizing him for being too
mean or something like that. Is it not
the case that he constantly says, "Oh,
it's just a joke. It's just a joke."
Like you're taking too criticizing him
for being mean. Okay. Is being mean a
serious criticism?
>> Just here. Is it not the case that on
his stream he literally says, "Oh, we're
just laughing at things, guys. We just
find things funny, you know? We just
find it funny. We're not
>> laughing or being mean a serious
criticism."
>> Okay. You're not serious. Okay.
>> Answer the question. Okay. No. again to
to reiterate. Okay. Your claim was that
Queman will make serious No. Shut the
[__] up. Shut the [__] up. Shut the [__]
up. Shut the [__] up. Your claim your
claim food shops. Your claim was that
Queman will make serious criticisms and
then when he is pushed on those, he will
back down using the excuse it was just a
joke. And then you said, okay, I
actually have an example. He was mean to
me and then said it was a joke when I
pushed him on it. Is being mean a
serious criticism?
>> Yeah. I mean, is it not
>> being mean to someone is a serious
criticism.
>> It's kind of funny. It's kind of funny
to me that now you're like pivoting,
right? Because before I literally told
Sorry, you're moving on point. You're
the only one that's tried to pivot.
You're the only one that's tried to
pivot. I'm kind of trying to push back
on things that you No, you're moving the
goalpost. You're moving the goal post.
I'm not moving any goalpost. I'm asking
you for any example. I know that is
being mean a serious criticism. Is being
mean to someone a serious critique. You
literally said, you literally said,
"Give me an example where uhqman
responds seriously to something and
doesn't just like handwave it away with
like, oh, just saying it's a joke or
something." Is that not like a serious
critique that he's just handwaved that I
gave you an example of? What do I have
to call a clip now? Like how you don't
even know what you're saying? You don't
even Okay, your claim again for the
third time. Your claim was that Queen
will make a serious criticism. This is
something Quean will do. Queman will say
a serious criticism. Okay. Queen will
say a serious criticism and then he will
be pushed on that and then when someone
pushes on him, he will respond back and
say, "Oh, I was just joking. I wasn't
serious."
>> You can hold on. You can laugh at it.
You can laugh at it back then, right?
Obviously, it's a [__] gay ass
complaint, right? But back then, the
thing is is that like, yeah, it is
actually a serious criticism. And
honestly, this is where we're at now,
right?
>> Women being mean is a serious criticism.
No, hold on. Food shops. Food shops. No,
no, no, no. It's very he didn't take it
seriously. Like it's very clear to me
seriously because Maxer makes an edgy
joke and now he's in trouble. So
>> food shops. Food shops.
>> Yeah.
>> Is Queen being mean to someone doing a
serious criticism
>> is Yeah, of course. What the [__] So
now you
What is a critique?
>> A critique is that you're making a
complaint about someone.
>> Okay. And if someone's being mean, how
is that how is that gate? You don't need
to specifically define like I'm pretty
sure you don't need to specifically
define what the [__] a critique means.
No, like you're
do because you're saying being mean to
someone is a critique when it's not.
Being mean is being mean. It's not a
criticism.
>> What? Okay. So when I if I call you a
[__] is that a critique? If I say
that you're like a pedophile, is that a
critique of you? No, it's just [__]
talk.
>> That is very different from a a pointed
criticism like he's being too mean.
That's not a critique. Hold on. If my
friend was being too mean to me and I
tell him that he's being too mean, is
that not a critique?
>> That is you critiquing them. Quean being
mean to someone else is not Queman
critiquing someone else. That is the
claim that you made.
>> No, I'm I'm specifically No, I'm
specifically talking about someone
making a critique at Queman. You're not
even keeping up with the conversation.
>> I understand what you're saying. Your
claim again for the fourth time now.
Your claim for the fourth time is that
will make a serious claim against
someone and then when he's pushed back
on about that claim, he will retract and
say it's a joke. When has he done that?
>> I've been talking about when has he done
that ever? Name one time. I don't need a
clip. I don't even need a clip. Name one
time.
>> You're literally missing my point
entirely.
>> Name one time. Just name one. Just name
one, please.
>> No. The entire time I've been saying
someone else making a [__] critique
towards Quan, not Queen making a
critique towards someone else.
>> You were making that [__] [__]
You're literally pivoting. You're
literally pivoting.
>> Pivoting. Hell, the entire time I've
been
>> You're changing. You're changing your
[__] position.
>> Okay.
>> All right.
>> Change the goal post. Whatever. Go
ahead. Max Striker. Go ahead. You're
like a [__] like stupid [__] who,
you know, is not consistent. Whatever.
Max Striker. Go ahead.
>> Yeah. No. No. I mean I mean you won't
you won't even let me finish. So why why
should I like every single time I begin
to talk you just like start interrupting
shouting? So it's like whatever.
>> Okay. Well, that's not every single
time. I obviously going to let you talk.
Are you going to [__] talk or not?
Done [__] Holy [__] Max Striker. Go.
>> Okay. Okay. Let me finish. So Max
Striker. Okay. So, my critique is that
the modern Bailey of commentary is when
oh, you're critiquing someone. When
you're making a critique towards someone
like being mean or being too edgy, it
seems as though they will say something
like, "Oh, well, I'm just I'm just I'm
just being funny. I'm just being funny."
All right. But then when they need to
attack, they are actually making
complaints. They are actually making
principal positions. So what it comes
like to me uh comes off to me is that
since Queman right since Queman doesn't
really care about being edgy or whatever
Max Striker making an edgy super chat
saying oh yeah I got it Queman I got it
Queman assignment understood yes I
acknowledge it's an edgy joke yes but it
seems like because he doesn't
acknowledge like this whole critique of
him being too edgy or his audience being
too edgy right in trouble in the first
place.
>> Huh?
>> Is it bad to be too edgy? I mean, maybe
when people can tell whether or not
you're joking, maybe it doesn't. Isn't
>> that a part of the joke sometimes?
>> I mean, then
I I can understand where you're coming
from. I can understand the the baseline
of where you're coming from, right?
>> But when someone is literally called
[__] Max Striker Films and everything
they super chat, everything they tweet
is like a a exaggerated joke, I I I
don't think and they're like an in
community meme. I just don't think like
this is a strong point.
>> Hold on. Is Will Yeah, but is Willie Mac
and Destiny supposed to know who Max
Striker Films is?
>> Yeah, they should probably do research
and look into something if they're going
to critique it, right?
>> What? Okay, so
>> specifically has an issue with research.
He does poor research consistently
constantly, right?
>> Unreasonable. That's actually so
unreasonable. And you know that is
that's crazy.
>> It's unreasonable to critique a [__]
super chat to begin with. You can't
control your audience. You can't control
who super chats you.
>> Okay? Like for example, Mal, I don't
even know all the members of your
[__] audience. And you don't know
mine either. I wouldn't hold you to that
same standard. That's [__] insane.
>> And I wouldn't hold someone to the
standard that they got [__] super
chatted by someone called Max Striker.
That's a [__] critique.
>> If you got Okay, hold on. Hold on. Hold
on. Food shops. Food shops. Food shops.
Let me give you a hypothetical. Let's
say, hold on, hold on, hold on. Food
shops. Let's say you got donated by
[__] loi loi rapist [__] 1488 or
some [__] right? Do you think it would
be a fair response for someone to say
like, "Dude, look who donated to food
shops. This is crazy. Look at this. This
is [__] insane." You think that's a
fair like critique against you?
>> Hell no. But like is Max like a [__]
Wait, hold on. Let me finish. Let me I
answer your question. Let me finish.
>> So is Max Striker films a eco example to
Lolly liker striker 69? Is that the eco
example? Max Striker films? I think so.
>> Explain to me because both of them are
like inflammatory. Both of them are
inflammatory. That's the point of their
>> How the name isn't even close to being
edgy to Wall-E Striker 69. That's
[__] insane.
>> Have you seen their like Twitter
account? Have you seen their like
YouTube account? Like what what do you
mean? Yes, it is inflammatory.
>> Okay. Oh yeah,
>> they literally lar as a [__] Nazi.
There's lightning bolts in their room.
They literally LAR as a Nazi. That's the
joke. That's the big
>> is laring as a Nazi. Uh-huh. Yeah.
>> Okay. It's it's there is contention on
whether it's LAR or not. That is true. I
you know, deep down there's probably
something there. I agree with that. But
yes, it is a it is it is Mamma is Mama
Max's [__] name. The Twitter account
is like larping as a Nazi. It's like
Yeah, it is obviously a joke. It is
obviously satire. You can you can argue
say like, "Oh, I don't think it's
funny." But yeah, obviously it is a
joke. Like obviously it is satire what
he's doing, right?
>> Okay, that's great. I'm just saying from
the outside perspective looks like like
Queen's doing hint hint wink wink kind
of [__] So
>> it absolutely does not. You have to be
absolutely [__] insanely [__] to
ever [__] believe that.
>> That's crazy. If you literally if you
get if you get donated something that's
K if you get donated something that's
funny are you just like not allowed to
respond even if it's like of like a like
we got to we got to [__] we got to
drop this guy at the Empire State
Building like no obviously not a joke.
Nobody's doing call to actions. Queen
actively says like hey don't go to this
person's chat. Don't do this. Don't do
that. Don't [__] harass people. Don't
target people.
>> What are you talking about? It it's
really [__] hard to tell whether or
not
>> you're a [__] autistic [__] but
the average person is not having this
much issue trying to figure out if this
[__] is like satire or not.
>> No, I can't tell if you guys are being
autistic retards because the thing is
that I can't believe you guys don't know
how other people view it from the
[__] outside. Especially when
Queenman says like, "Oh, Joshua Moon
wins. Oh, Kiwi Farms is always right."
Like the thing is that it's very clear
he appeals to the Kiwi Farms.
>> Okay, let's let's switch to that cuz I
don't think we're going to get anywhere.
I don't think we're going to get
anywhere in the next striker. Let's
switch to that. He literally he
literally praises Kiwi Farms all the
[__] time.
>> Let's switch to that. Let's switch to
that. Let's switch to that. Sure, let's
switch to that.
>> No, but it's all part of one argument.
You can't just ignore like that part and
just
>> Queman in my chat just said, "I don't
say KF is always right. That's not
true."
>> Okay. I mean, he can say that, but I
remember hearing that. So, you know,
>> you remember hearing that?
>> I'm so glad that we're not Well, yeah. I
mean, that's an Let's
KF [__] Let's switch to the Queen and
KF [__] Let's switch to that. We're not
going to agree on the Max Striker thing.
Let's just leave that in the where we
can keep arguing about where I don't
think we're gonna find middle ground.
Let's switch to the Kiwi Farm [__] Is
that okay?
>> Wait, why should I? What the [__]
Concede. Concede, [__] Concede.
Concede. Concede.
>> No, I disagree with you.
>> You mean concede?
>> Okay.
>> I Well, I asked you to concede because
you admitted that you were in the wrong.
Okay, this is not the same. Let's switch
to the KF shut. Uh, how is even if
Queman agreed completely with KF or
liked Joshmoon or or was a fan of Josh
Moon, which I don't even know and he
seems to deny in my chat, let's just say
that that's true for the sake of
argument, right? Uh, how is that like
complicit in doxing or like a dog
whistle that people should go on KF and
start doxing people?
>> Well, Kiwi Farms likes doxing. So, if
you like [__] signal to [__] Kiwi
Farms and then you have someone making
that joke, like don't you think someone
from the outside will just simply go
like, "Oh, wow. Well, I guess like
Creman is doing H and Wink and it isn't
just an edgy joke. Like if Max Tracker
Films did that in my chat obviously like
it might be a little bit like like more
of a joke just mainly because I don't
glorify Kiwi farms like that. No,
>> sure. Can I ask a question?
>> Sure. Go ahead.
>> Uh why does
>> What's your answer to that? What the
[__]
>> I I thought you were I thought you were
It was rhetorical. Can you repeat it?
Sorry.
>> Okay. So, if we're accepting the premise
that Quimman does appeal to people from
Kiwi Farms and he does in fact say
something,
>> I don't think he appeals from people.
Let me finish. Okay, so if that is the
case,
>> hold on. If that is the case and then
someone from the outside sees like Queen
and like [__] Max Struggger Films
donating like, oh yeah, implying that
they're about to dox or do something to
Willie Mac, right? Is it not the like
correct inference to connect these two
together and say, "Yeah, I I'm not sure
entirely if it's a joke or not." And for
Willie Mack, who's literally been
docked, for him to go, "Oh [__] this
might be an actual threat or something."
Uh, if I were to concede it like first
glance, sure. But again, these people uh
have an abundance of time, they pay
researchers, they pay writers, they can
afford to look into this stuff and
figure out that it is indeed a joke and
this is not true. And yeah, Willie Mack
should have looked into this and and
should have understood that this is not
true. Willie Mack in his video that he
put out has a ton of issues. He
blatantly lies and smears both Queman
and Jtock multiple times. I don't I
don't I don't like that Willie Mack did
that and I
>> I agree. But he has an issue with
research. So this criticism that you
have, Sure. Even if I agree with it,
which I don't completely, he should have
looked into it. He should have
understood that this was a joke, that
this was not a serious [__] threat.
Uh like, hey, go to KF and go [__]
ducks and and do whatever. Right now,
can I ask my question? Yeah, but then
but yeah, but then this is just where we
disagree and it's like we can't move
past this.
>> Okay, we disagree. I'm going to ask my
question. I'm going to ask my question
then. Okay.
>> It's unreasonable to look into Max
Strucker films specifically as a [__]
chapter. That's insane.
>> I'm going to I'm going to ask my
question. Okay.
>> Mhm.
>> Why does Destiny get a pass uh for his
support with KF during the Keful [__]
Uh but somehow Quean doesn't get that
when he says like Josh Moon is based or
something.
>> I'm sorry. Did Destiny receive a
donation saying assignment received? I
got you. I'm going after Keeffles.
Did I
>> Why does Destiny get a pass with his
support for Kiwi Farms during the Keful
[__] but Queman doesn't when he says
Josh Moon is based?
>> Because Destiny haven't said Josh Moon
is based. Hello.
>> He talked to Josh Moon on a Turkey Tom
streaming with him and he likes him,
right?
>> Yeah. So, what the [__] He's not trying
to make a preemptive
>> Why does Destiny get a pass with his
support for Kiwi Farms during the Keful
[__] But but Queeman doesn't when he
says Josh Moon is based.
>> You think saying Josh Moon is based is
the same as having a cordial
conversation with someone?
>> Yeah, I think the cordial conversation
probably implies more support than
saying
>> that's not that's not equal whatsoever.
No, I disagree.
>> Yeah, I agree. I No, I agree. It's not
equal. I think the cordial conversation
live streamed is probably more
endorsement than saying this person.
>> Saying that saying no, wrong. I
disagree. I think if you say I'm going
to ask my question again. You you keep
pivoting and you keep avoiding it. Why
does Destiny get a pass with his support
for Kiwi Farms during the Keful [__]
but Queman doesn't? Now,
>> hold on. Hold on. If Destiny had a
cordial conversation with Techone, does
that mean that he endorses everything
that Teeone does and that Tee with him
is like he's trying to appeal to Tees's
ground.
>> Let's use Aerodite as an example.
>> Not necessarily. Obviously, not
necessarily. Obviously, context matters.
>> Okay. Are you going to
>> Are you okay? Let's even [__] Yeah. I
think it means one of two things. Either
one, you're you're fine, perfectly fine
with what they're alleged of, or two,
uh, you just like didn't look into it at
all, right? Which I don't think is the
case with either Destiny or Queman,
right? I don't even know if Queman
endorses Kiwi Farms or or or null. I'm
going off of what you say for the sake
of argument, right? So, I'm I'm going to
ask my question again. Don't pivot. I
want you to engage with this question.
Don't do what aboutisms. I really want
you to try to engage with this. Okay?
>> Why does destiny get a pass? Hold on,
hold on, hold on, hold on. Why does
destiny get a pass with a support? Hold
on, hold on, hold on. Why does Destiny
get a pass with the support for Kiwi
Farms, including offering to fund them,
bankroll them, and Quean doesn't now?
What is the difference there to you?
>> Bank them.
>> Yes, he offered to fund them.
>> [__]
>> Destiny offered to fund Kiwi farms
against Keels.
>> What specifically?
>> Against Keels.
>> Engage with the question I just gave
you. Engage with that.
>> I'm going to have to ask for I'm going
to have to actually ask for evidence on
that. I can't just accept that premise.
I'm sorry. And even if it's even if it's
true, right? Isn't his main contention
against Keles?
>> Engage with the question, please.
>> Like, isn't isn't isn't the whole
context?
>> Why does he got to pass? Cuz his entire
engagement is with Keles, not like
specifically with like [__] with
trying not trying to appeal on his own
[__] time in a vacuum, right?
>> Uh, so I have a post from three years
ago.
Destiny offers to fund kiwi farms on
stream to spite.
is on the Vos Reddit.
To be clear, he didn't follow through.
He did not give them any money. He just
said that he would.
>> Um, this page does not exist.
>> You need a screenshot of it.
>> Sure.
>> Why saying Disney?
>> I don't know why it's saying it doesn't
exist for you. It exists for me.
So again, I I really want you to try to
engage with us. What is the difference
here? If one of these people is
obviously offering more support, more
overt support, saying, "I will literally
give them money." Right? Okay. Destiny
is saying, "I will give these people
money to support their right to exist."
How is that somehow worse than Queen for
some reason? I I again, I have not seen
this. I'm just going off of what you
said. I'm I'm giving you the benefit of
the doubt saying it's true. How is that
somehow uh you know not as bad as Quman
just saying like I like null?
>> How is Destiny offering overt support
less bad?
>> Hold on. Let me explain. Let me explain.
Hold on.
>> Sure.
>> So he gets the pass. The reason because
is because he was currently in a [__]
huge magnitude beef with Keles at the
time. And Keeles was the one that was
misrepresenting Kiwi Farms, right? And
>> dating them.
>> Hold on, let me finish. Let me finish.
So at the time when the drama was going
down, obviously since Destiny was
beefing against Keles and was trying to
do a steelman for Kiwi Farms at the time
and trying to like defend Kiwi Farms
against like Keeles, that is not the
same whatsoever as Queen on his own time
on his own stream making an appeal
towards Joshua Moon and Kiwi Farms.
These two things are not identical
situations. What was saying about Kiwi
Farms?
>> She She was basically, oh yeah, they
were doxing her. They were sending pizza
to like her [__] um house. Oh, she
moved locations, but then they kept on
sending like food towards her, right?
>> Okay. Is that not what is that? Hold on.
Hold on. Is that not what Destiny is
saying about Kiwi Farms about other
people right now?
>> What? He's saying that Kiwi Farms is
like sending pizza to someone's house or
some [__] to us.
>> He's saying that Kiwi Farms is doxing.
Kiwi Farms is doxing Willie, all of
these people. It's because of JTO. It's
because of Quean.
>> That's what he's doing right now. He's
doing what? He's doing what you think.
>> He has literally
>> Okay.
He has literally not said that. And even
if he did, I would just
>> Okay.
>> Okay. So, he hasn't said that, but even
if he did, you're saying, "Hey, so hold
on. You're saying you're saying
food shops
>> and Jason directly are organizing
doxing. Okay. All right.
>> I'm not saying that. I don't think
that's true. I don't think there's any
evidence for it. I'm saying that's what
Destiny's saying.
>> Wait, wait. Yeah. I don't think Destiny
said that. Proof.
>> Okay. Didn't he literally make a chart
uh saying like Okay. What?
>> Yeah. If someone has a clip of that,
send it to me. I'll forward it.
And what you're saying is that Destiny
said they explicitly organized doxing,
right?
>> Uh I believe so. Something something
along those lines to the same effect.
Obviously not. I don't know word for
word.
>> I'm curious. I I I'm curious as to this.
Okay. All right. I would love to see
this.
>> Yeah, sure.
organizing doxing specifically, not
coordinating narrative against him. Yes,
we're being very clear on this.
>> I believe I believe he is calling other
people doxers while explicitly trying to
dox them when there's no evidence that
these people are doxing anyone else.
>> Okay. Well, I'm specifically talking
about a claim, a very specific claim,
but okay, we'll see.
>> Uh okay. Yeah, I don't have proof for
that claim. I don't care. Engage with
the question that I've been asking you
for like 30 minutes now, please. I don't
give a [__] about that.
>> Yeah, I'm not Yeah, sure. You can you
can do your whole victory roll. Why does
Destiny get a pass and Quimman doesn't?
>> Unless you want to sit here for like 5
minutes and wait for someone to send me
a clip.
>> Okay. And she just left. Yeah. Based.
>> Yeah. I don't I don't know what you guys
want. I'm not going to sit there for
like 10 minutes and wait for [__] one
of my 50 [__] viewers to send me a
[__] clip. I'm not going to do that.
What clip do you want? I don't give a
[__] now.
You push too hard, dude. It's either I
push too hard or I don't push enough. I
don't give a [__] They're They weren't
They weren't ever going to engage with
that question. And I think that's
[__] telling. Okay.
Because they have a double standard.
Somehow when Destiny does something,
it's perfectly fine. But when Queenman
does the same thing, but significantly
less, not as bad.
So yeah, it was either sit there for
[__] 10 minutes in silence waiting
for someone to send me the [__] clip
or try to push her on that point and end
the conversation early. I'm fine that it
ended early. She can do her whole
[__] cope session.
She can do her whole [__] cope
session. I actually won. I actually won.
They were never going to engage with
that question.
You know, there was no way. No, I knew,
dude. I said this even before I [__]
talked to him. Rewind the stream. Their
mind was never going to be changed.
Literally, all that was going to happen,
it was going to be like entertaining at
best and at worst, it was going to be
like them not engaging with anything.
So, thank you for the five gifted Kella.
Thank you for the 10 gifted Venomous.
No, it was never. To be clear, that was
never going to go anywhere significant.
To be clear, I knew this. I said this at
the beginning. This was never going to
go anywhere significant. Their mind was
never going to be changed.
Uh
yeah, I just didn't.
She described it as reciprocal doxing.
You don't need a clip. Oh well, maybe if
I was smart enough to bring that up at
the time.
This is the clip you wanted to DM it to
him. Let me watch it. I'll see.
It's not like they're going to watch it
on stream. Watch it be like porn. I'm
not verifying this before I clip on uh
click on it.
Using spicy chat for separation too. Um
using spicy chat for separation for the
bad behavior. Uh Jessica and Queen etc.
talk like 10 times more there than even
their own community. And all of the
biggest Kiwi Farmes psychos are there as
well. For example, uh they were recently
posting pics of of I mean, I guess I'll
say it, it's sad, but like of like um
Willie is getting married and they've
been like posting pictures of his wife
and [__]
>> To be clear, it was one person who
posted that picture and that person was
banned when mods were notified. To be
[__] clear.
>> Um and then joking about how he got
honeypotted by the IDF. Um, and then
three, then Queen and Justicle can
forever act above it, but a large core
of their fan base exists in and around
spicy chat. They can indefinitely call
doxing bad and pretend that Willie is
crazy, while ostensibly the core of
their community is directly part of it.
And I guess Chud logic just doesn't
count.
>> Listen, I sent it to him. I'm not going
to act like they're going to [__]
engage with this at all, though. So,
I'll send it to him. I'll be I'll be
good faith. I'll send them the clip I
said I was going to send them. Um, but I
do I do I think that they're going to
engage with it? care about any backlash
or having it attached to a server. He's
pretty much like Joshua Moon in that
sense. Um, null. Sorry for you.
>> He's like Joshua Moon. Yeah. Okay. And I
was just sent this by Kathy.
>> Okay.
But are you a subscriber to a guy that
hides accused sexual assaulters in their
house? I'm just kidding. In a video
game. The only difference is I talked
about giving money to a bad person and
you actually did it. I'm just kidding.
It's all jokes. It's jokes here. Okay.
Innocent. Is this the promoting K or is
this the funding Kiwi Farm saying
>> until proven guilty? There are possible
things that there are things that Miskf
and Maya could say if they're clever
enough. There are ways out of this.
Maybe there's another explanation for
things that have happened.
>> Why is there like a [__] cam girl in
the corner? What is this?
>> Maybe there was a miscommunication.
>> Go back more on the time stamp.
Because it's so easy to end up in a
situation where you're propositioning
somebody and they don't know what's
going to happen if they say no and you
run the risk of just everything falling
to pieces and getting completely [__]
And um
yeah, but technically technically X and
Train can really just say what what did
you expect?
>> 10 seconds. Okay. Well, send me the
[__] right [__] timestamp next.
Okay, 10 seconds. I'll go 15 just to be
safe.
>> No, literally how I don't understand how
you're saying I didn't explain it, but
I'm I'm
>> Misk mod. Destiny wanted to give money
to Kiwi Farms and doxes people and lead
to at least three suicides.
>> Which one?
>> Okay.
Are you a subscriber to a guy that hides
accused sexual assaulters in their Okay,
this is the
I guess the funding thing. Yeah. Okay,
sure.
Haha, I was right. [__] [__] food shops,
chat. True. Yeah, again, like it was
never going to go anywhere. It was fun.
I had fun doing that. I had fun doing
that, okay? But it's really hard.
Listen, there's a way better clip, too.
I mean, it this is like common
knowledge. I I was surprised they even
asked me to [__] prove this.
I thought everybody knew about this. Uh,
to be clear, that was never going to
[__] go anywhere. It's really hard.
Listen, okay, listen to me. It is
insanely difficult to try to have a
conversation with someone or debate
someone, however the [__] you want to
describe it, when they're willing to uh
to try to [__] virtue signal to their
chat by just leaving in the middle of
the conversation and and refuse to
engage in any questions that you find or
any questions that you ask. Uh, they're
critical of someone that they're
supporting because they get viewers from
it.
Um, add that with the fact that I'm also
a bumbling [__] [__]
The expectation should not have been
high. She was just lying. No, she was
just lying. I mean, I can't believe how
she tries to, and I say she because even
though she is a wretched, lying,
pedophile, Asian,
um, child rapist, nword, uh, killing,
nword hanging, nword lynching. I still
respect the pronouns. Okay. I still do.
Yeah. It's just like that was never
going to go anywhere. It's very
frustrating to debate with someone like
that.
Okay. I've been sent more screenshots.
I'll take a look at these.
I mean, this is just going to reaffirm
my opinion. Send these to [__] food
shops. I don't know. I don't know what
to tell you. Uh, Destiny. Uh, Bing B.
Uh, Big Bong. He wasn't doxed. I doxed
him. Giga Chad. I mean, that's my bad
for not verifying.
That's my bad. That's my I'll DM Riyle.
I'll DM Riyle. I I'll DM Riyle. [__]
[__] [__] [__] That's my bad. I
should have looked at the screenshots. I
assume that was her stream save.
What's the time stamp of the stream?
Hour 40 minutes. Let me write that down.
I'll edit it out of the VOD.
That's my bad. I'll DM him. I'll
apologize.
That's my bad.
Okay. I assume people were sending me
stuff to pull up on stream. That's my
bad. I am now an evil malicious doxer
and I'll do it again.
>> There's a better clip. We were actually
going to watch this video today. So,
this is uh towards the end.
>> The um
>> how much you think the monthly cost for
Kiwi Farms are?
I thought about actually doing a um I
thought about donating,
but there's like so much to consider for
that.
>> This is an outright endorsement of the
website and their practices. He also
>> I mean I don't want to spoil too much of
this video. I I was literally going to
watch this on stream. So yeah.
Yeah. Yeah, I mean it one of the most
frustrating things is when you are in
the middle of a [__] discussion,
you're in the middle of hammering in a
point uh of a double standard and then
they [__] leave. That is that is
blood boiling. That is [__] annoying.
Holy [__]
And what's even more annoying is uh
their chat is is like DG [__] So
they're all just going to, you know,
food shops one, food shops one.
It is what it is.
Then we have this. Would you donate to a
Kiwi Farms fundraiser?
Today, Destiny talked about possibly
donating or fundraising for Kiwi Farm
since it's being attacked by Keffles.
Would you help out? Why or why not?
Clip. Clip. Yeah. Okay.
When I when I have a conversation with
someone, and maybe this just isn't how
you're supposed to talk to people in
like Discord debates, I don't know,
okay? I'm obviously not a [__]
professional here. But when I talk to
someone, I have an air of good faith.
Unless their claim is extraordinarily
outrageous, unless their claim is like
mind-bogglingly out there, I won't ask
for a clip. I'll take them at their
word. Okay? I'll usually leave it at
that. And that way the chat can see if
they're lying, they can pull up a um
they can pull up a clip after the fact
and I can see like okay well they were
lying during this debate. That's kind of
sucks. But like during the debate if
someone says someone says something like
if food shop said like oh Queen said
null is based. Quimman said he never
said that but like yeah I'll go under
the assumption that he said that for the
sake of the discussion right I'll
obviously do that the same way that like
if someone tells me oh Destiny wanted to
fund raise for KF. I don't think that's
like that out there, especially during
the Keville's arc. I'll go along with
that for the sake of the conversation.
If they're lying, I have like a hundred
people watching me right now. If they're
lying, the chat's going to notice.
People can provide clips and then after
the debate's over, we can watch the
clips. We can see how they lied. We can
see how they [__] up. Stuff like that.
So, yeah. I I don't understand what
their obsession with like clips was,
especially like during their stream last
night, they were they were they did not
give Destiny any push back and then they
demanded a clip. It's like your entire
[__] stream. Obviously, I'm not going
to have a clip for that.
I'm glad the [__] discussion went
past the uh the initial like I need a
clip because if it ended there, that
would have [__] I would have lost.
Okay, I would have lost. I'll admit it.
I'll admit it. But yeah, no, generally
in a debate, I'll never ask people for
clips unless it's a egregious claim.
I'll just take what they're saying with
good faith, assume it's true, and then
continue with the conversation under the
assumption that that's true.
You debated food shops. Hey, don't get
your don't get your hopes up. Uh, they
left in the middle of it.
I kept trying to nail on the point uh
why for some reason Destiny gets a a
pass with KF but people like Queman
don't under the assumption that Queman
is pro KF which I don't even think he
is. Queman came into my chat and
literally denied it. So uh I don't think
Queman's going to start lying now. I
guess I should have checked if the if
the channel was real. That probably
would have been good. Um, but if that
Yeah, if that was the real Quan,
uh, then I guess that's wrong. I guess
they were just lying about Quean. Maybe
they misheard a clip. Maybe they
misinterpreted a clip. I don't know. I
don't know.
She was using it as a distraction tactic
to pivot. Yeah. No, she pivoted a ton.
It was very frustrating.
The dude, it's so a good [__] It's so
maddening.
It's so [__] maddening when you are
trying to be good faith. When you are
trying to be good faith and the other
person is being bad faith and lying and
pivoting and changing the goalpost and
doing all of this [__] and then they
accuse you of doing it. They accuse you.
Oh, you're you're you're being bad
faith. You're trying to change the
goalpost. It's like, dude, that's
literally what you're doing.
Good.
[__]
She's also legitimately [__] Yeah,
Queeman has been telling me this for a
while now. Queman has been telling me
this for a while now. Um, but yeah, no,
I I don't want to believe people are
liars. I hate thinking that people are
liars, especially K the it is like it is
it is hard for me to believe that food
shops is a liar when they are willing to
talk to me. They know my positions on
things. They know what I'll say about
things. Uh, she'll get into a call with
me. There is like no reason for me to
believe that they're a liar. So, it's
very frustrating uh when in my point of
view they are lying. They're being
extraordinarily [__] dishonest.
Uh even though they're open to talking
to me. Usually when people lie, they're
like, "No, I'll never talk to you. I'll
never [__] get in a call with you."
And it's like, "Okay, well, I I can see
why you're being dishonest. You don't
want to get confronted on that."
Whatever. But then food shops will just
get in a [__] call with me.
[__]
assume uh everyone is malicious. That I
that's just like a bummer way to think
about people though. I don't know. I
mean, I I'm probably getting to that
point slowly, but I I I I want to give
people the benefit of the doubt. I want
to believe that people aren't [__]
like lying cretins.
It's also the reality.
I listen. Okay. What's that book? Treat
otter how otter would want to be treated
or whatever.
What is this? It's like a children's
book.
Do unto otter.
This book I dude I read this [__] in
like first grade and this this [__]
stuck with me. This [__] stuck with me.
Do unto otter, a book about manners.
This [__] stuck with me.
This [__] stuck with me, man. All right.
[Laughter]
You know, I Yeah. I mean, realistically,
I should not go into conversations with
like that much good faith. I just don't
want to believe people are like [__]
malicious lying freaks.
I never read that book. I'd steal your
wallet and help you look for it. Yeah.
with money that you gave me. By the way,
you're you gave me the money, I put it
in my wallet, then you stole it back and
like, "Oh, that sucks. That sucks.
I don't know." Again, to be clear, I've
watched like one queen involved on food
shops. I don't know their history. Are
do they have a history of of of lying?
Maybe. I I I don't know.
It It's the same thing with like
Stardust. I haven't looked into Queen
and Stardust coverage. My opinion on
Stardust is um is unique to me. It is
unique to my experiences with them. You
know,
I'm waiting for the next losers creeps
and pedos thumbnail to feature food
shops.
[Laughter]
I got to get better at like arguing. I
got to figure out how to [__] talk to
people. I'm like socially inept. I gota
like uh who's that one guy? Andrew
Wilson. Andrew Wilson. I got to take the
Andrew Wilson debate course.
What is it? Hold on. How much is Let me
Andrew Wilson debate course. Yeah, I'll
check Gen Chat in a sec. Debate
University.
Oh, there's a trailer.
Oh [__]
[Music]
Your job is not to show mercy. Your job
is not to back off and allow them to
>> My job isn't to show mer there's my
first mistake. I'm doing everything
wrong.
>> To maintain their false ideas. That's
not your job.
>> It is nebulous. I understand it's
nebulous, but I'm also not the one who's
making the affirmative claim. You are.
>> So, let's start with some dirty tricks.
Some dirty tricks. Some kind of hitting
below the belt. God damn it.
>> You're still whining. Stop whining.
>> I will smack any discussion.
>> Seriously, does your dad say, "Thank you
for prostituting yourself so I have air
conditioning."
>> Well, now as we hang on, let me finish.
My turn. Sure. Go ahead.
>> So, as we dive into this though, by the
way, you say that you can't make a
deterministic statement.
>> Wait, is a deterministic statement?
>> How? Again, how dumb are you folks? I
want to watch that.
>> Debate is a weapon. Especially in the
21st century when living in the
information age.
>> This debate is over. Goodbye.
>> Goodbye, jackass.
>> I'm not interested in your stupid
paddle. Answer my question. That makes
no sense. That's the stupidest thing
I've heard out of you tonight. Why would
you do anything if you
>> one Indian [__] [__] I DM'd her
asking to edit for her, but then I
realized it didn't pay a lot, so I left
her on red.
Okay. How much does this cost?
Course online.
Where's the Where's the price?
How much does it cost? Buy this course.
$250.
What the [__]
What? For five years though? Oh, okay.
It's like $50 a year. That's a steal.
50 bucks a year.
How many How many That's like $7 a day.
That's like $3 an hour.
Wow. $3 an hour every single day, 24
hours for five years to learn how to
debate. Should I do a dono goal for
those?
If I
I paid Andrew Wilson to help me learn
how to debate and I took on five of the
world's greatest debaters. Make a
YouTube video out of it.
I took on my local what is it? Congress.
I took on my local congressman to on a
debate after after paying Andrew Wilson
$250.
[Laughter]
You should have debought this after you
lost the debate to Papa God. I didn't
view the Papa God thing as a debate,
but I understand what you're saying.
Expose how bad it is from the inside. Is
it bad? Is this a scam? Are there
allegations that this is a scam?
After you complete the course, you
debate them on getting your money back.
True.
That's a good idea.
You should review it if it gets paid for
me. [__] yeah. I'll do it.
Listen, folks. Like, sub dono. All
right.
Like, sub, dono, and I'll pay Andrew
Wilson. I'll become close personal
friends with Andrew Wilson if I get
$250.
Debate master dono goal.
Should we watch? Um, hold on. Andrew
Wilson Vosch.
Is this funny?
the most bad faith debate I've ever had.
Do I need to be bad faith to win against
transgender pedophiles? Is that what I
need to Is that what I need to resort
to?
[__] [__]
dude. I had I had a I lost the image. I
lost the picture.
I lost the picture. I had a um I had a
moral a moral vos avatar at one point.
I [__] I lost it. It it was had to have
been like close to two years ago by now.
Maybe a year ago actually. I don't know.
I had one. I had a moral vos moral my
name on Discord. Uh when I would I I
because I did like [__] when I was
covering [__] like a year ago on my main
channel. I would um
hold on. I could find it. Hold on. Let
me find it.
Let me find it because I want to show
it. It was really good. I thought it was
super funny.
Another useless derail. It's going to
lose me viewers. I'm a professional
streamer. I want you guys all to know
that.
I want you guys all to know that.
Is this a stream?
This is This is it.
I found out or this is one of them at
least.
You can see at the right here. See that?
Look at that.
You guys see that? That's me. That's me,
baby. That's me, baby. Right there.
Right there,
[Laughter]
dude. I wish I still had the [__]
picture. I wish I still had the [__]
picture. [__] [__] So sad.